this video is sponsored by girl cafe gun
the world of entertainment is an
absolutely bizarre one but one we can't
seem to take our eyes off of we can
idolize celebrities obsess over them
that sometimes it may seem like they are
some unreachable objects that can be
sold objectified and commodified so much
so that there are some of us that can
forget that they are just like us
people but what is it like behind all
the lights and glamour how much of what
we've shown is based on lies and deceit
and what is it like to be one of these
celebrities does your favorite girl
really love you
well of course she doesn't you
delusional [ __ ] oshinoko is a manga that
explores these exact topics now for the
longest time i was one of those anime
fans that would get confused whenever a
new show would be announced and all
these manga readers would scurry out and
be hyped about it but now being in japan
getting exposure to the hottest new
titles i think i finally found one
oshinoko is a series where it's only a
matter of time before this gets licensed
and it is too good to not get an anime
adaptation eventually and i'm just happy
to be on the other side of the fence for
once for that so i just wanted to talk
about this a bit today but before we get
on to this series i just wanted to talk
about today's sponsor girl cafe gun let
me tell you about girl cafe gun it's got
girls it's got guns and it also
has a cafe
probably girl cafe gun is a new action
rpg that combines high-intensity
third-person shooter gameplay with live
2d interactions and management systems
that all look absolutely great i was
actually really impressed with the
gameplay which resembles the old school
top-down bullet hells which not only
tests your reflexes and mechanics but
you also need to manage your team comps
and strategies going into different
stages but come on guys we all know the
real reason we're here you've also got
all these amazing girls you can collect
with a diverse bonding system to get
closer to the girls you like and
increase your relationships with them
and don't forget you get to run your own
virtual cafe with them as well it's a
game that combines many different genres
and systems but you know what it's like
they cherry picked all the little things
i look for and put them into one game
you'll be dodging bullets one moment and
then patting your wife whose head the
next so really what more can you ask for
if like me this looks like everything
you want in the game then click the link
in the description to try it out today
you can also use the code on screen
right now for free gifts thank you again
to girl cafe gun for sponsoring today's
video and with that said let's go back
to talking about oshinoko it's one of
those titles that is worth giving a
chance just because of the names behind
it coming from the same artist that did
scum's wish written by the mangaka of
kagi osama because while still writing
and drawing kagiasama doing a weekly
serialized manga which is famous for
pushing many artists to their limits aka
akasaka was just like
let's start another one
but despite the names behind it you
wouldn't be able to get what this manga
is about just by reading the synopsis or
the beginning i mean this was my
experience reading chapter one okay so
we've got some idol story here that's
cool and um
what the [ __ ] gynecologist what the [ __ ]
teen pregnancy what the [ __ ] he's
already dead
what the [ __ ] he's the baby now
what yeah you heard that right the main
character is an idol obsessed
gynecologist who finds out that his
favorite idol is pregnant promises he's
gonna deliver the baby then gets [ __ ]
murdered by one of her obsessed fans and
that gets reborn as a [ __ ] baby i say
again
what the [ __ ] i thought i was getting
some idol manga then by the end of
chapter one i had enough physical
whiplash to give me neck problems but
then the babies have memories of their
past life and then they can talk and i'm
just like what the [ __ ] is this mushoka
tensei gynecologist reincarnation did i
just stumbled on some [ __ ] idolisa
guy but trust me when i say this strange
premise doesn't really have much to do
with what the series is actually about
well kinda it's hard to explain there is
a major subplot i don't wanna spoil but
the premise basically just gives this
convoluted reason for i's son aqua to
become an actor and follow in his
mother's footsteps and starting his
journey into the twisted world of show
business it's an unfiltered look at the
japanese entertainment industry from the
eyes of the people working behind it
it's raw it's real and oftentimes it can
get pretty dark resulting in what i
think is one of the most promising
titles to be released in recent years if
anyone was a big fan of act age and like
me was
severely disappointed in what happened
then in many ways oshinoko is my
spiritual successor showing people in
the acting field breaking down the
talents and commitment it takes to be a
successful actor but unlike act age this
series isn't just limited to acting
idols reality shows tv dramas stage
plays the series takes you on a journey
through the underbelly behind the scenes
of the japanese entertainment industry
and shows you what it means to be the
people behind the camera up on that
stage with hundreds or thousands of
people cheering you on what it takes to
get there and the effect it can have on
any individual who finds themselves in
that position the manga doesn't pull any
punches when it comes to its depiction
of the modern entertainment landscape
not to say it's all doom and gloom i
mean come on it's coming from the same
author as kagi osama but it doesn't shy
away with just
showing things for what they are the
series literally starts off dismantling
the idol industry openly embracing the
entire industry as a facade a fake image
sold by how talented the stars on stage
are at
being liars i hoshino's whole existence
is in a world of lies her lies to her
audience
is her form of love it is a lie we buy
into and not only does the series
straight up tell you that but it can
celebrate it as well no matter what
sector of entertainment it explores it
never stops reminding you that show
business is a show
business everything is deception
everything is marketable everything can
become a commodity but underneath the
surface the real strength in the series
is aka akasaka's ability to write
sympathetic characters behind the fame
and glamour are real people people that
have to live in this world of deception
people who have to deal with the
pressures of being constantly judged not
only by their audience but the industry
they work in what i love is that aside
from maybe the main character how human
everyone feels everyone has all these
little insecurities and anxieties that
you can relate to and
these only get enhanced by working in
the entertainment industry to say that
entering the cutthroat world of show
business won't be detrimental to your
mental health is a bit like saying
entering the jojo fandom will leave you
with an unsucked dick
[Music]
and the manga doesn't pull any punches
when exploring the effects of this
industry on the talent's mental health
it humanizes these inhuman idols it
makes you see the twisted world they
have to live in and one thing that
impressed me the most was that it did it
in a way that's all the more relevant
right now traditional celebrity culture
has thankfully been on the decline in
recent years we can all see that they
are all also human some of them have
flaws and a lot of them are very very
out of touch with the current times and
we can all agree that paparazzis are
below dung beetles in the social
hierarchy
alright maybe that was a bit harsh
dung beaches are actually good for the
environment within the place of that has
been the rise of the social media
celebrity before celebrity figures might
have felt like they were up on this
pedestal untouchable and unreachable but
now some of the most influential figures
have never been more relatable more
seemingly in reach and thankfully the
author seems to be very in touch with
the modern landscape because social
media plays a massive part in many of
these stories i was pleasantly surprised
when i saw stories about people trying
to become successful youtubers and
instagrams and tick tocks because i was
like yeah yeah
now you're coming in my neck of the
woods it was surreal seeing a manga that
was basically centered around my career
and industry and coming from the inside
seeing these stories based around
influences and their culture
it does a [ __ ] great job alright i'm
about to go on a tangent that doesn't
seem like it has anything to do with
anything but trust me i do have a point
and it does relate back to this [ __ ]
manga all right here's a little secret i
really hope won't come back to bite me
in the ass in the future by admitting i
often wonder how i would handle
getting cancelled okay this is not to
[ __ ] say that i sit in front of a
mirror rehearsing how to say i've made a
severe and continuous
lapse in my judgment nor do i think
there's anything i've done which i'm
scared is gonna get exposed and i'm
gonna have to apologize about but as a
youtuber whose career is tied to my
online presence and image council
culture and how to properly manage that
has become a massive factor in my job it
can be something that ends careers or it
can be something that you brush off and
move on from but regardless no one is
immune to its effect no matter how much
you think someone is uncancelable let's
talk about apology videos for example if
you think about it apology video should
be a simple affair someone does
something wrong so they apologize and
then people forgive them or they don't
but nowadays people getting cancelled
and creative apologies have become so
commonplace that it's almost become a
cliche good apologies bad apologies over
time we've been exposed to the entire
[ __ ] spectrum so much so that you can
even say that there's even a [ __ ]
meta for youtuber apology videos that we
can break down parody and sometimes even
rank and that's because
apology videos aren't about being sorry
it's about winning back public favor
it's pr
even if the person is actually sorry
like if i had to make an apology video
regardless of if i was being genuine or
not it's actually irrelevant because all
that's important is about making you
believe that i'm being genuine and
unfortunately being genuine and trying
to convince a mass audience that you are
being genuine are two entirely different
things now this may seem like a strange
tangent to go on that may look like i
have a weird obsession about the thought
of getting cancelled but that's because
i was astonished when i saw oshinoko
dealing with this exact topic not only
does it portray what happens when you're
just flooded with hate comments that
puts you in this self-destructive loop
you can't escape from that gives you
this
suffocating feeling which i can never
truly describe in words to someone who
hasn't been in that same position but it
also addresses how fickle public opinion
can be and how easily it can sway and
even the tactics and strategies you can
use to sway it to your side and game the
system they have a full-on death note
style breakdown of the mechanics of
getting cancelled and how to uncancel
yourself and i was absolutely amazed
reading this because some of this stuff
was exactly the same stuff i've thought
about because that's just what the
ecosystem has become so the biggest
compliment i can give is that from
someone working on the other side of the
industry is that oshinoko was pretty
spot on with its portrayal he managed to
make a super compelling story arc out of
it and made me feel not like a
psychopath for thinking this deeply
about getting cancelled i made it severe
this is just one of the story arcs that
the manga has dealt with in the many
facets of japanese entertainment and
regardless of if i've been as familiar
with them as this example so far they've
all been as equally compelling and as
far as i can tell as equally well
researched right now there are only five
volumes out in japan so it's still very
early days but i only see this growing
in strengths
there are so many facets it still could
explore i mean i honestly wouldn't be
surprised if there was an arc about
youtubers in the future with how much
aka akasaka is in touch with the modern
entertainment landscape also for the
record kaneiro's best girl i've claimed
to back off weebs keep an eye out for
this title in the future because if i
was a betting man this is getting an
anime adaptation one day and yeah that's
pretty much all i wanted to say this is
a great manga so let's just go straight
to the outro thank you again to girl
cafe gun for sponsoring me today as you
can see i am back in japan this video
was not pre-recorded at all i literally
started working the moment i landed you
know what i'm just happy to be doing
more manga videos so i'll probably do
more in the future say hello to the
manga zone also not taking a break from
doing things after i've landed but i'm
going to be moving next month i'm
planning to change a lot with my studio
upgrading my desk and possibly doing a
new background so look forward to that
so yeah that is my month of october
sorted and i'll hopefully have time to
make videos in between all that until
then though i'm happy to be back i've
been up and i'll see you all next time
bye